I'm a Latinx son of immigrants
from a small Texas border town.
Growing up, I didn’t have
access to classical music,
and I had never been to the symphony.
But I always knew that I wanted
to play a string instrument.
So in sixth grade,
we got the opportunity to pick
our instruments for orchestra class.
I took one look at the viola
and said, "Great, that'll work."
And as I began to play the instrument,
I immediately fell in love with it.
Even though my middle school
orchestra director
was a fabulous bass teacher,
she could only teach me
so much on the viola.
And because there weren't
any viola teachers in my town,
to be able to play the things
that I heard in my head,
I turned to a teacher
who seemed to know everything:
YouTube.
(Laughter)
By watching countless hours
of YouTube videos
of the great virtuosos
performing everything from Beethoven
to the musical suite from "Star Wars,"
I tried to mimic their techniques
and incorporate them into my own playing.
With a few difficult years of practice,
a lot of blood, sweat and tears
and the endless support
of an entire community of people
who really, really wanted me to succeed,
I began to play in places
that I'd never even dreamed of,
like Carnegie Hall,
and bring my music to audiences
across four different continents.
It had been one of the most difficult
learning experiences of my life,
but one that proved an important point:
anyone from anywhere
can do incredible things,
if you connect them with the knowledge
and resources that they need to thrive.
On my travels, I became friends
with the elite young musicians
who seemed to have all the resources.
Because they lived
next to musical capitals
like New York, Chicago or LA,
they studied at places like Juilliard
on the weekends.
They watched their teachers
perform at major symphony orchestras.
They had access to almost every
musical opportunity that you can imagine
right in their home communities.
And even though I was proud
of the hard work that I'd done
to get to their level,
I hated always feeling behind
because I never had access
to private lessons.
So you can imagine how excited I was
when I had the opportunity to take
my first professional private lesson
with one of the best violists
in the world.
I just knew he'd be so excited about
how much progress I'd made on my own
and encourage me to become
a professional musician.
So it came as such a surprise
when he told me to quit.
(Laughter)
He said kids like me
who didn't start playing at an early age,
who didn't have access to private teachers
and the best resources,
who didn't really understand
how the classical music industry
really operated,
generally could not make it
as professional musicians.
Now, classical music
is incredibly competitive
and sometimes people
with all the resources don't even make it.
So I'm sure he thought
he was doing me a favor,
and maybe he was, but I was shocked.
It hurt.
But I didn’t want to disrespect him,
so I smiled, said, “OK,” and left.
I was a 15-year-old who loved
playing the viola more than anything,
but in that moment I seriously considered
putting my instrument away forever.
Now I'm 21 years old
and I couldn't be more grateful to have
experienced that moment of discouragement
because it opened my eyes to the fact
that for 13 million children
in the United States
who live outside of major US cities,
pursuing a career in something
like classical music, ballet, art,
research or many other
historically exclusive fields
is incredibly more difficult,
if not practically impossible.
In classical music, for example,
people of color make up only
around 15 percent of America’s orchestras,
despite representing almost
42 percent of the US population.
So in some ways, I don't blame
the viola teacher for telling me to quit.
Music opportunities
tend to cluster around major cities,
especially the charities and nonprofits
that try to help underserved students.
And I just wasn't around them.
But people have talent everywhere,
and everybody deserves a chance
to grow that talent
and share it with the world.
Because when we allow people like me
to systemically be prevented
from entering into
these competitive fields,
we uphold the elitist
and exclusionary systems
that allow so many children to be told
that they're not worthy enough
to pursue their dreams.
I wanted to change that.
For many years, I had no clue how.
But when the COVID pandemic hit
and our entire world went virtual,
I saw an opportunity
to help others learn music online,
regardless of who they were,
where they lived,
or what they could afford.
So I texted a few friends
I knew from around the country
and put together a founding team.
Together we reached out
to 20 other musicians that we knew
and asked each of them to teach
a free virtual private lesson a week
to an underserved young student.
This meant that students like Samuel Igbo,
a 14-year-old violinist
from a small town in Texas
who dreams of pursuing a career
as a concert violinist,
could receive personalized
musical mentorship from Nikki Naghavi,
a prize-winning violinist
at the New England Conservatory.
My idea inspired and connected
hundreds of people from all walks of life
to offer their time and expertise
to aspiring musicians like Sam
from around the country.
And now, just two and a half years later,
this little idea has turned
into Through the Staff,
a national nonprofit
that has provided almost 600,000 dollars
of free virtual private lessons
to almost 1000 young musicians
from Fresno, California
to Wilkesboro, North Carolina.
I didn't realize it, but I'd accidentally
started a virtual nonprofit.
We didn’t just use the internet
to deliver our services,
our organization existed on the internet.
Because our program
was run entirely by volunteers
from around the country
who work together for a common cause,
despite never meeting once in person.
Because our students and teachers
could learn from each other online,
wherever they were,
geographic boundaries no longer mattered.
This digital workspace meant
virtually no startup or scaling costs.
So we've been able to grow
and make incredible changes
with a budget of only 9,000 dollars
over two and a half years.
It was only after I began to see
this profound potential for impact
that I realized that virtual organizations
can help us better distribute
educational resources
directly to those who would
benefit from them the most.
And if this worked in classical music,
I figured it can work
in other places, too.
This time in academic research.
When I began to explore
biological research
in my second year of college,
I remember trying to find a mentor
and being discouraged
to only see white male researchers.
Just like in music,
this trend is systemic.
Only 15 percent of all doctoral
researchers were Native American,
African-American or Hispanic.
I wanted to change that.
And I knew that
the virtual nonprofit model
that I had already developed
could make a difference here, too.
I could start something that could help
generations of future young researchers
break into academia.
So in 2021, my best friend and I gathered
a founding team of 31 college students
and started another virtual nonprofit
called the Pre-College Research Institute.
Together, we've created
four 32-hour virtual research courses
that have taught, trained and inspired
160 high school students of color
from Klerksdorp, South Africa
to New Delhi, India,
to Alpharetta, Georgia.
If I could break down barriers
in access to music and academic research,
anyone can do it anywhere.
That's exactly what makes
virtual nonprofits so powerful.
They transcend geographic boundaries
and bring opportunities to those
who would literally never
otherwise have them.
They're a new way
to find and connect the world
to a huge source of untapped talent
and a necessary step to nurturing
the future of these industries.
This is the future that will not only
change the fabric of these institutions,
but ensure they survive
and prosper for years to come.
And as more and more children
are connected to the opportunities
and knowledge and resources
that they need to chase their dreams,
I'm excited to see the people
that lead every industry
look a lot more
like the world around them.
I know this transformation can happen,
but I can't do it alone.
So if you have an idea or interest
for how to make a historically
inaccessible field more equitable,
grab a few friends,
brainstorm a way that you can break down
the barriers in your field
and start a virtual nonprofit.
You may never meet the majority
of the people that you serve,
but the effects of your hard work
will touch them in ways
that they will never forget.
Thank you.
(Applause)